the pittsburgh steelers will host the
baltimore ravens
finally
we think
wednesday afternoon 3 40 p.m eastern
week 13 scheduling changes we now see
washington and pittsburgh is moved to
monday 5 p.m eastern network tbd cowboys
ravens actually shifted to tuesday night
805 pm eastern as part of the fox
typical thursday night package and
bill's 49ers will be in arizona not in
santa clara on monday night 8 15 p.m
eastern on nbcsn so lots of early prime
time football next week because of the
midweek raven steelers game and look
chris
what happened yesterday
and we wrote a story about this that
really caught fire and within a half
hour the nfl moved the game
baltimore players
were threatening to refuse to play the
game tonight
not because of covet 19 concerns but
because of their own physical safety
resulting from the fact that they
haven't been allowed to practice they
haven't been allowed to prepare you're
going to throw these guys to the wolves
that are the pittsburgh steelers with 20
guys unavailable with a bunch of backups
and slappies thrust into play with no
chance to get ready to play after being
shut out of the facility for a week they
had real concerns about their own safety
they were not ready to go forward with
the game and they were considering
refusing to play and that leveraged the
nfl into moving the game to wednesday in
fact the players wanted to go to
thursday the compromise ended up being
wednesday the players are fine with it
now the union was concerned about what's
called a wildcat strike where you go out
on strike during the term of the cba
where strikes are illegal but there are
certain circumstances where you can do
it could have been a huge mess for
everyone involved they averted that
disaster by moving the game from tuesday
night to wednesday afternoon yeah i mean
it's amazing i you know i was shocked
that it got to that point that's serious
you know like when i first saw the
headline i just thought oh yeah the
players there might be rumors out there
but i mean from what you're telling me
it got to the nfl that this was a real
union was involved yeah union was scared
and here's what here's why union was
scared right now that it's not going to
happen i mean we we've alluded to it
yesterday
if you violate this agreement that was
reached in august to allow the season to
proceed the nfl could just rip the thing
up and throw it away and say okay no
agreement we're just gonna we're gonna
pull the plug on this season because we
are swimming in red ink with fans not at
these games it's worse than we thought
it was going to be we're just going to
end the season and and my reaction was
well but they're making they're still
making money off of the tv deals and
they're going to have more revenue
but but they don't the union's like well
we don't really know whether or not
they're making money we don't know and
people don't want to find out the hard
way
if we violate this agreement
and the league says thank god we want
out of this season
they've got no reason to tell us how bad
it is financially if it is bad so that
was the concern if the ravens players
crossed that line and breached that
agreement there was a chance there was a
concern there was a very real fear the
league was going to say thank you we got
our early christmas present let's get
out of this season while we can but that
seems i don't think that was going to
happen i know but they were concerned
there was a concern that that that was
the first domino the ravens players
refusing to play would lead to that
potentially there was concern about it i
agree with you i don't think it would
have happened because the fans would
have lost their mind well yeah and
you're going to have a lot more red ink
when you have to write checks to fox and
espn and nbc and cbs they go hey yeah
we're not playing and so sorry so that's
going to be you want to talk about red
ink
that that
the whole thing is amazing it really is
i have so many thoughts here i don't
know if we have a lot in long enough
time all right here's my first thing why
are the steelers playing monday night
why i don't understand that the steelers
have done nothing wrong and they're
gonna get the shorter week than the
ravens that makes no sense to me ravens
sorry about your safety that you didn't
necessarily seem to care about as an
organization the last 10 days but now
you care okay
and they're gonna get the longer days
for the next game to prepare
why is that that's the first thing that
jumped off to me it pissed me off
actually as a guy who used to be a
player rep and all that the team that
has that fault gets longer next week to
prepare than the team who sat there and
did everything freaking right that makes
no sense that's the first thing i want
to challenge the nfl on do you have any
inkling of why that would be
well i i the steelers don't have a
travel obligation between these two
games right yeah are they they're at
home for both ravens and for for
washington so you don't throw a travel
in there home and away and also hey you
know you want you want to bump it to
tuesday you still got a game the
following sunday you're either going to
play monday and play the following
sunday or tuesday and play the following
sunday so i think it moves on that
happened today they should move that
next sunday into the monday but it's
ixnay on that because it's
it's steelers it builds on nbc so let's
not start asking for that so uh i i
think that you know when you consider
that their game after this is washington
at home the game after that is at
buffalo i'd rather play monday than
tuesday if i'm the steelers
i'd rather have washington at home
monday and then focus on buffalo instead
of having washington home tuesday and
then have to figure out what i'm going
to do against the bills with only five
days between games so i my guess would
be that's probably the realest probably
prefer it this way uh i guess i guess
you're right i mean hey i i really
thought like of this if i was
if i was the head coach of the
pittsburgh steelers or mike tomlin i
mean do you even think about
just going damn this is just not good
for my team we forfeit fine ravens win
no not playing that like no
no we've been no we've heard all year
that this isn't going to be a fair
season that people are going to have to
make sacrifices on adjustments that
things are going to happen the steelers
have navigated ten games winning them
all they are not going to let go of the
i know
the ship just because the waters have
turned rough that's the last thing
they're going to do but it's that's
terrible to everything mike thomann
believes i know but it's also scary it's
where i worry you know injuries with
this many games in a short period of
time and all of a sudden you lose three
four guys here for the year and then
you're going damn well there goes the
super bowl that goes undefeated
everything uh so i don't know i'm just
throwing things out there that have
crossed my mind i hear you yeah this is
the ultimate stuff happens season
although there's a different word that
starts with us and has one fewer letters
store high in transit
exactly um
now
it and and so many of these different
angles and wrinkles of the season don't
really crystallize
until you're standing
up against the front door of it and
yesterday
when it looked for a while like there
was some tension maybe in the league
office science versus sport
some who wanted to push this game to
week 18
versus those who wanted to say damn the
torpedoes let's get it in yeah so i
started thinking about week 18 and why
the league won't push a game to week 18.
and
that steelers bills game that we talked
about right for me was was the
the catalyst for understanding why the
league is waiting
if you postpone raven steelers and say
we're going to play it week 18 this is
our first game yeah of what could be
several in week 18 you slam the door
on any other game involving the ravens
and steelers being postponed to week 18.
if there's an issue with any of those
other games those games necessarily are
gone forever you can't play two games
that week if you're the steelers or the
ravens so the buffalo game what if the
bills have an outbreak next week and
that game needs to be postponed
well sorry we've already put raven
steelers in week 18
steelers bills just won't happen
i think if they ever kick a game down
the road chris i think they won't even
say it's going to be played in week 18.
they're just going to say tbd
because you want to
reserve the right to prioritize later
right but then how do you prioritize who
wins we've got let's say we would get to
the point where raven steelers is
postponed steelers bills is postponed
you can only play one of them in week
18. what the hell do you do
how do you determine which one is more
important wow to the integrity of the
season that's when it hit me
they don't want to go to week 18 unless
and until it's in week 17
and those are the games that get pushed
back one week other than that they don't
want to do it yeah i can understand that
i mean that's that's a whole can of
worms that it would really cause issues
i don't even know you're right how do
they do that i don't know where that
goes if you add another week that just
would seem it would be unfair to some
teams in this uh but yeah that could
have major playoff implications if that
were the case seating who gets in who
doesn't you know you even with the eight
teams per conference talk there you
could get into a scenario like you're
talking about where you go
wait there's nine teams that deserve to
be in that we're not really sure how
this unfolded and now we're just gonna
say hey you ate get in uh so i
understand all that i do that that's
dicey very dicey and i understand the
nfl wanted to hold off on that as long
as possible
but it just shows you how
because we're living in these crazy
twilight zone times
you know we've been just assuming all
year long week 18 week 18 week 18 you
don't quite understand what week 18
means until you're on the doorstep of
week 18. and and i'd like to think that
there are people far smarter than me in
the league office for a variety of
reasons but i'd like to think they've
already known this
and they've factored it in now they
weren't sharing it with anybody
but
but now i think i understand why they
don't want to do it because yeah you can
i mean somebody's only playing 15 games
which means somebody's getting in based
on 15 or being excluded based on 15
where that one extra game could have
made a huge difference and like if
you're the ravens all fine we don't have
to play the steelers hey we get in
sorry uh oakland raiders uh las vegas
raiders any raiders wherever they're
from now sorry you don't get in we get
in because we didn't have to play the
steelers that second time because of an
outbreak that we were partially
responsible for yes we're in and you're
out not that the raiders would be the
most sympathetic victim in that
situation given their own covet 19
misadventures but that's i think that's
why um so game tomorrow night
or late afternoon
3 40 p.m eastern that's weird it's weird
yes strange but at least we're going to
get to see the game we get to see rg3
against the steelers defense uh and all
that that implies
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports